today's guest is jord hameroff who along
with roger penrose has a theory of
consciousness
what's particularly interesting is that
roger penrose is a rigorous physicist
bordering on mathematician which means
even more rigor
and generally speaking those people tend
to stay away from theories of
consciousness
that aren't simply emergent from
material complexity
however hammeroff and penrose have a
theory that combines
general relativity with quantum theory
and it's in fact
in this unification that produces
consciousness within what are called
microtubules though it doesn't
necessarily need to be within there
this is a technical talk and we didn't
even get to half the questions
there's quite a bit of jargon and that's
because i believe that one needs to
speak with a certain level of
domain-specific language if one is going
to make progress
otherwise we stay at the jejune level if
you're merely listening to this rather
than watching such as on spotify or
itunes or you're away from the monitor
there are concomitant visuals in the
youtube video
for those unacquainted the point of this
channel is to interview those who have
contributions to a theory of everything
and then for you and us to collectively
via discord
via the subreddit come to a greater
understanding of the laws that govern us
and god and free will and so on
there is a clips channel called toe
clippings with shorter
shareable segments from these larger
interviews i welcome people to submit
theories to me
and to each other but it's quickly
becoming overwhelming
so at some point i will host informal
chats with audience members on their
theories of everything
on the toe clippings channel since this
main channel
is heavily dense with information and
plenty of preparation plus editing
it would be great to keep it that way if
you'd like to see more conversations
such as this then please consider
donating at patreon.com or if you're
simply interested in the general mission
once 50 patrons is reached we'll host a
friendly constructive conversation
rather than a critical one with bernardo
castro
donald hoffman and jonathan verveicky
enjoy so stewart how was your day ah
hi kurt it's great uh i'm in california
with my wife
and uh we're kind of taking it easy
today so i'm happy to talk with you and
catch up did you perform any daily
ritual
any meditation any special diet today no
usual well something i noticed about you
was you're extremely quick-minded astute
and and lucid and then i looked up your
age
and you're past 70. i hope i'm not
spoiling anything
but i'm curious how is it that you're
able to stay so quick-witted
and articulate well i'm still working as
an anesthesiologist i'm on vacation at
the moment but
uh um i stay active i have
keen intellectual interests as you know
and love life and savor every moment and
uh
just keep going were you always like
that
probably yeah do you pray do you believe
in god uh
i do i in my own way i uh
my beliefs are kind of personal and in
tune with my own personal beliefs but i
was raised in a religious family and
got uh you know got that from them
and uh i'm very grateful my parents and
my family for
my upbringing including including my
religious i kind of rebelled against
organized religion but
believe in uh and something uh
that organizes the universe some kind of
uh
uh
probably conscious function that
organizes the universe
i find that most people who study
consciousness have a dislike for
institutionalized religion
yeah but they like spirituality in some
way shape or form
yes right so why don't you give the
audience a cliff notes
version of your theory okay um
well i got interested in the problem of
consciousness when i was in
uh undergrad uh and i took a philosophy
of mine class i was a chemistry physics
math major pre-med uh it was also the
late 60s and we did things then that
people did then
and uh there was a lot of political
turmoil social unrest as you might
imagine
and uh i got really interested in this
velocity mind class
but went to medical school and in
medical school none of the particular
specialties i like the brain mind
problem but neurology psychiatry
neurosurgery
didn't appeal to me in terms of
lifestyle and stuff to do
i stumbled into anesthesiology but while
i was still in medical school i did a
research elective thinking i might like
academics
and i was in a cancer lab studying cell
division how cells divide mitosis
and you know the chromosomes the genes
are genes are pulled apart by these
structures called mitotic spindles made
of microtubules
and that perfectly separates the
chromosomes the genetic material
and everybody else in the lab i'm pretty
sure got into the genes and went on into
genetic
engineering and all that but for some
reason i got
fixated on these structures that pulled
apart the chromosomes
and if they didn't do this delicate
dance perfectly
the genetic material would not be
perfectly divided and you'd get
abnormal mitosis you get mal development
you get
cancer and so forth so i got interested
in the structures that did the
mechanical movement
and at that time in the early 70s it was
appreciated that they are also
in neurons the neurons were full of them
and their structure was revealed and
they had a lattice structure
and that looked to me something like a
computer matrix because i was
trying to figure out how computers work
computers were new to me anyway back
then
in the early 70s so we had the so i was
interested in consciousness
i looked inside neurons and there was
all these structures that looked like
little computers so i got the idea that
these microtubules as they were called
might be processing information
and uh subservient uh consciousness at a
level
below neurons because as you know almost
everybody else thinks that the brain is
a bunch of
is a computer of neurons each neuron
acting as a simple
on off switch yes or no a bit of one or
a zero and if you get enough complex
computation
among neurons you get consciousness
emerging in some way
but yet there were single cell organisms
that do very clever things they can swim
around find food find a mate have sex
learn and so forth and they were a
single cell so if a single cell
paramecium can do that for example i
thought it's kind of
an insult to a neuron to say it's just a
one or a zero depending on whether it
fires or not
and so i i started i got interested in
these microtubules
inside neurons so uh a year is
a year later a couple years later when i
was looking for a specialty to do in
medicine
i thought about doing pure research and
decided against it
um but i stumbled into anesthesiology
because the
the guy who would become my my future
chairman a guy named bernell brown a
really
brilliant and charismatic character
became a good friend of mine and my
mentor
said if you want to figure out
consciousness figure out how anesthesia
works
and two here's a paper on showing that
anesthesia acts by depolymerizing
microtubules that you're so fond of
what does depolymerizing mean it means
they fall apart
they disassemble so there are lattice
microtubules are lattice polymers of
individual proteins called tubulin
each tubulin is just one protein like a
peanut
shaped protein but by entropy they they
this is really weird how entropy drives
something
so uh elaborately self-organized they
they self-assemble into these hollow
tubes
and grow like like girders or
scaffolding right i was watching this
talk by
anarban i believe yes right right right
and they self-assemble and they grow
they grow cells and they make
neuronal connections and they do
everything uh in terms of cell movement
cell organization
so uh it so if you give enough
anesthesia and it turns out it takes
about five times as much anesthesia
to cause them to disassemble to to
depolymerize into their
to go from these elaborate uh polymers
structures into the individual
individual proteins
uh enough anesthesia will do that well
that's about five times the anesthesia
you need to cause them
to cause unconsciousness so fortunately
we don't uh
cause our microtubules to fall apart we
just affect them in some
more subtle way fortunately although too
much anesthesia can do that
so anyway uh brunel uh my future
chairman said
you can figure out consciousness it has
something to do with microtubules
it's a lot of fun and it's pretty good
money so that was
a long time ago and i went in anesthesia
and here i am 46 years later still doing
it clinically
and still enjoying it and the research
has you know given me an opportunity to
kind of go where i want to go then you
started collaborating with penrose and
i'm curious about the practical aspects
of that we can talk about it later
but i'm super curious to know what is it
like to collaborate with penrose how do
you do it do you use a whiteboard
what's an example of a problem that
you've tackled together recently but
we'll talk about so you
encountered penrose i should say before
i get to roger i should say that i spent
about
20 years working on microtubules as
classical information processing devices
going around to
artificial intelligence meetings neural
net meetings neuroscience meetings
saying
hey to understand the brain you can't
just think of the neuron as a one one or
a zero
you got to go into the deeper level and
again all this additional information
so for example that you know ai
singularity people were saying well you
have
10 to the 11th neurons are switching at
about a thousand
per hertz see about 100 or a thousand
synapses 100 hertz gives you about
10 to the 16th operations per second and
kurtzweil and singularity were saying
well when we get to 10 to the 16th we'll
have
brain equivalence and consciousness but
i said well no
if you have the microtubule subunits
about a
billion of them or uh per neuron
switching at uh 10 megahertz you get 10
to the 16th
operations per second for every neuron
so
uh the goal post for ai was i was
pushing it way down
down the field and uh they didn't like
that you know they
said go away you bother us you know what
are you doing because they wanted the
singularity to happen in their lifetime
exactly you know give them another you
know a couple billion and they'll have a
brain equivalence
you know in in another few years so i
thought that was bs
um and i thought their their approach to
the brain was an insult
to the brain an insult to neurons and i
was going around uh
doing my thing being pest um
and then one day somebody said ask me a
very good question he said
um let's say you're right wise guy wise
ass
and all this is going on how does that
explain consciousness
how does that explain you know love joy
feelings pinkness
envy taste you know uh what later became
known as the hard problem by
according to david chalmers and i was i
was a bit stunned i had to admit they
were right i really didn't know
and uh i had enjoyed being a pest but i
didn't really have a solution other than
we had to look deeper and the same
person suggested i read this book by
roger penrose called the emperor's new
mind
and i had vaguely heard of penrose but i
didn't really know his work this was
well he wrote the book in 89 and i think
i read it in 91
um or so and uh it was
uh quite a tour de force as you may know
it it covered
the main the main point was it started
off with through girdle's theorem
arguing that um consciousness requires
something other than computation
other than what we think of as classical
computation
or just other than computation even
quantum computation that there had to be
something else
because uh girdle's theorem uh
to prove a theorem in mathematics uh you
have to be outside the computational
system
so we extrapolate extrapolated that to
say that
uh to uh for understanding for us to
know any
to know something to know anything we
need something outside of the
computational system
of the brain basically the neurons
firing out fire
and uh i didn't i didn't follow all it
got into the weeds in terms of
philosophy and mathematics
that kind of lost me but intuitively uh
it was
i felt he was onto something and he was
at least questioning and had the same
gut feelings that i did that there was
something more to it than that
and uh but his answer you know what that
something
was what the missing ingredient was
got into quantum physics and a
self-collapse of the wave function and
his own theory
of the measurement problem and in
quantum mechanics
as you as you may know you can have
superpositions of multiple coexisting
possibilities
things can be in two states or places at
the same time and yet when you measure
or observe them
they become one or the other so the very
active measurement
or some people thought the very act of
conscious observation
seemed to cause collapse of the wave
function and the other idea is that
each possibility coexists and continues
and forms its own universe
or that the coherence does it or the
bone theory or this or that uh
and uh they all have their flaws and
they all have their appeals
uh but rogers was that well the first
thing he did that
was really kind of mind-blowing and
still is after all these years is that
he explained superposition
which nobody else has even attempted to
do as far as i can tell
so the question is how can something be
in two places at the same time how can
it be here
and here the same thing in two different
places and
he he he saw that by by resorting to
general relativity
by saying that uh as as you know for
very large objects like the sun
there's curvature of space time this
goes back to
einstein's general relativity and so
einstein had predicted that a star
behind the sun
could be visible in an eclipse because
the space time curvature
would bend the bend the light around the
space-time curvature and we would see it
even though we knew it was behind the
star and in 1919
eddington uh went to the top of the
mountain during the eclipse
and proved einstein right that there was
these these big curvature in space-time
and we could see these stars behind the
sun
in an eclipse so um basically einstein
equated uh
mass with curvature and space-time
geometry for large things
roger applied that to small things and
said a small thing like a quantum
particle
approach on an electron or something at
the quantum level
uh has a has a very tiny curvature and
so
if it's over here there's a curvature
going this way if it's over here there's
a curvature going this way
so it being in two places at once was
actually two separate curvatures
a separation and space time so the
fundamental level of the universe
that he called space-time geometry and
which he cleverly portrayed as these
two-dimensional sheets
could separate and uh you could imagine
that if they continue to separate each
would have its own universe and you'd
have multiple worlds
but he said these separations were
unstable and after time t
would would self-collapse to one or the
other
and and t was was inversely related to
the amount of
separation so a very large separation
would self-collapse
quickly and a small one would take a
long time and and here was the kicker
and when that collapse occurred to one
of the other there was
a moment of consciousness that was
created or occurred or emitted depending
on how you want to describe
it so this was the opposite of the idea
that consciousness caused collapse
in roger's view collapse occurred
spontaneously due to this
property of of the universe and created
consciousness cause consciousness
almost like a quantum of consciousness a
quantum man
and uh and so he he turned the the
so-called copenhagen interpretation and
consciousness causes collapse
around and said collapse occurs
spontaneously and causes consciousness
and he did it with these clever drawings
and not a whole lot you know
there's plenty of math and equations
that i didn't follow
but i got i got to just because he's
more uh creative and
well he's more expressive in terms of uh
illustrations and
his clever cartoon he's extremely visual
yes yes and artistic and uh you know he
he's also involved with m.c escher and
and that's kind of a whole sideline but
but um you know i was able to grow grop
what he was saying intuitively
and uh so he was saying at the end that
well you there needed to be some kind of
quantum computer in the brain that would
self-collapse by the by this threshold
but that neurons firing or firing were
were too big
so he already knew that neurons were too
big but he didn't have a candidate
for a quantum computer and uh so we're
reading this after spending 20 years
uh working on microtubules at a smaller
level and i knew a little bit about
quantum because
there had been a guy named frolic
herbert frolic in the 60s and 70s
who claimed that there was quantum
coherence in in geometric
biological lattices uh that were in a in
a
geometric uh constraining geometric
lattice geometry pumped by by heat
and in a common voltage so the heat
which normally
would destroy quantum events was
actually pumping it more like a laser
than
than another kind of quantum quantum
state
and so i knew a little bit about about
frolic and uh
and and um and frolic i had met with
frolic and
uh he liked the idea of microtubules
being these frolic uh
oscillators coherent devices is he still
alive
no he died in 1991 he got a long time
ago actually i see i see
we were going to have a conference for
him uh we had arranged a nato advanced
workshop to bring in a lot of people
talking about his
his theory but unfortunately he died uh
a couple months before the conference
we had which we had anyway it was a
great conference but um
now uh but he died in uh i think it was
91.
but i but i have something called frolic
residences right which president follow
coherence
they just came out actually in the
fizzrev a
uh my wife just gave me the reference uh
a new paper by
a guy uh aristid delgario at university
of central florida
about frola coherence and it's it's a
brand new treatment and it's very pro
pro frolic and actually i know uh rsd
actually we're working together on
another project
so yeah frolic coherence uh actually
suffices for the kind of quantum state
that
that uh roger needed if you had the
right
uh structure and i i thought it applied
to microtubules so
anyway i wrote to uh to roger and when
after i read his book and and said that
i really enjoyed it
and uh thought that uh microtubules
which i described in a letter
might be the quantum computer inside the
brain that he needed
and uh and that i by the way was going
to be in england for a meeting
a couple months hence and be happy to
discuss it with them and i was uh
thrilled
and delighted to get a uh a letter the
old-fashioned kind in the mail
yes happy to meet you come meet me at
the
mathematical institute at oxford in such
and such a day and time
and so i did and uh he actually uh
i think he met me at the train station
we walked over and
uh sat in his office for several hours
actually
and uh i did almost all the talking he
just asked me a few questions about
microtubules and i brought a book that i
had uh written about microtubules and
several articles
and uh when we went through all the
illustrations what sorts of questions
did he ask you
he said the first day first thing he
asked me was are these things real or
biological
or or matt or or computer simulations
i said oh they're definitely real
they're all they're all living cells
make up mitosis and i show them lots of
pictures
and uh and so he was particularly
interested in that
in the geometry of the a lattice
now microtubules can form in two
different types of lattices
the a lattice or the b lattice and the a
lattice
has a fibonacci geometry and roger is at
heart
geometrist your geometry and the
fibonacci giant
you have these spiral helical windings
of the tubulins
and if you go if you follow one pathway
they repeats every three every three
tubulins
another every five and another every
eight and then 13 and 21 the fibonacci
series
so the in the a lattice the the
fibonacci geometry was
was intrinsic to the lattice and he said
if that's
if alas could be could be a quantum
device just because of the young teller
effect
and and so forth and uh
i also was looking deeper inside each
tubulin to these
pi resonance aromatic amino acids
because i knew that's where anesthetics
act
and so forth so anyway he liked the idea
and uh although um i didn't think at the
time going back to the meeting in oxford
i didn't know if anything would come of
it although he did mention
that he was going to a conference at
cambridge with dan dennett and pat
churchlin two
philosophers of mine uh big names and uh
that uh you know it was gonna be about
consciousness
and i thought gee i'd be really fun to
go to but i was going to a different
conference
neural net conference somewhere else so
he thanked me we said goodbye
and i said well that was cool i got to
meet roger penrose and i didn't
think anything would come of it and uh
two weeks later i was back in london
heading back to the states
and had dinner with a friend and he said
hey guess what my friend went to this
meeting in cambridge and roger penrose
was talking about you and your damn
microtubules oh great
and uh i was thrilled i was just tickled
to death so um
i said well that's even better and then
a few months later i got invited to a
meeting
uh that roger had arranged to get me
invited to
it was obvious in sweden
a very limited uh basically speakers
only meeting
north of the arctic circle and in in the
midnight sun which was
dan dana was there and uh petra story
and a few other people
and um roger and his wife vanessa and uh
we were there for
about five days and uh you know the
meetings were doing today but
with no no darkness we just stayed up
and talked and went skiing at night and
walked and
played ping pong and did all kinds of
things like no darkness
pardon me you said with no darkness it
was above the polar circle in sweden
during the midnight sun there it was
like
okay july or august uh way way north
so uh mid no uh you know midnight sun
and we actually went skiing at night uh
on a place on the
i think it was the norwegian swedish
border
and uh it was a lot of fun and
got to know him a little bit and at that
meeting i invited him to a conference
that i was or
i was organized the first tucson
conference the science of consciousness
in tucson and it was the first
interdisciplinary conference
and i invited him and bribed him with a
trip to the grand canyon
and uh not that i needed to bride him
but he he was
happy to to go and so he was at the
first conference
which we held in 1994 the science of con
or he's called then toward a science of
consciousness
and later we changed to the science of
consciousness so we've been doing that
every year
either in tucson or elsewhere since 94.
so he's the first one he's been back to
probably five or six of them was it the
first one that 28 year old david
chalmers was there
and you went on a hike yeah david
chalmers and his famous talk
yes uh so let me tell you since you
mentioned it i'll tell you the story
about that
so i was i was the main organizer i got
uh al cassini
my friend for psychology and alex l
scott from mathematics
to organize it and uh
the internet had just happened so we had
email but most of the correspondence was
by fax and this and that
and the idea at the time was to have the
first day on philosophy the second day
on neuroscience the third day in
cognitive science
the fourth day on math and physics and
biology and the fifth day on phenomenal
experience which in retrospect was a
huge mistake
because what you really want to do is
integrate you know different different
approaches
on a given topic i see it i think but
that's so that's the way uh
you know out of naivete we set it up so
the first morning was philosophy and the
first two speakers were well-known
philosophers
who got up and and uh literally read
their talks
their papers with no slides and that's
that's what philosophers did back then
some of them still do but they've come a
long way and uh
and and after the first two talks
everybody in the audience is
they're going to sleep they're like
totally you know the energy the
philosophers dug it but everybody else
was like what the hell
but then the third talk was was chalmers
and he was
an unknown postdoc who had kind of
lobbied me by
email to give a plenary talk every it
was either plenty of your posters and he
said i don't give a poster
and his his abstract was about the hard
problem versus the easy problems
and problems i said okay what the heck
so he
he was the unknown third speaker and so
he got up
and uh woke everybody up out of their
stupor
uh because he gave a great talk exciting
talk
he you know was hit he had hair down at
his waist and strutted back and forth
with an australian accent you know kind
of looking like mick jagger
prancing back and forth saying yeah
memory attention
all this they're difficult but they're
relatively easy compared to why we have
conscious
experience well we have qualia so he
just went off on the hard problem
and was that the first time he
introduced it publicly
yes yes and uh
so after after his talk was the coffee
break and i went around like
a playwright on broadway you know
listening in and people go oh the hard
problem the hard problem that's why
we're here
and he really galvanized the movement so
from that point on i think there was a
a kind of a unified field of
consciousness studies
uh from that that talk on and we became
good friends afterwards and he
uh dave uh tagged along to the grand
canyon with roger and a bunch of other
people
and um you know we've been friends ever
since
how has your theory of consciousness
been modified by penrose
well my theory was just a more com
computational
some would say ad nauseam you know more
more complication at a deeper level
so it was hierarchical and it was at a
molecular level but it didn't it didn't
utilize
the quantum i knew about frolic but i
didn't really and i said yeah and that
gives you unified coherence which
consciousness had
but uh it wasn't quantified in any way
so roger
uh uh you know when we uh when we met
and said you know we can kind of put
this together in a theory
and he said yeah well uh so he handed me
uh in a quick actually a couple couple
weeks afterwards or maybe a month later
we met up again in denmark
a long story but i had a couple weeks
off and i took my son and we we hung out
in denmark where i had done my
my sabbatical where roger and vanessa
also hung out because
strange story their dentist was there
from years ago they used to go there and
see their dentist and hang out in
in denmark and uh there was a conference
and i got roger invited the conference
so we stayed at a house together on lake
lumbee
and uh and began to develop a theory and
he would give me kind of an assignment
and uh you know i felt like a student
which i was really in terms of physics
and math and i'd you know
stay up late and do this algebra
basically and come back with an answer
he's okay so now we have to do this and
that
what was an example of one of those
exercises was it related to t
equals h bar over e and calculating yeah
it was almost all
related to to that so roger had given me
that equation going back to the to when
he was in tucson for the uh the
conference i said well how do we
quantify that
and he said well we have to we have to
put the uh
we have to put microtubules into this
equation
uh t equals uh h bar over e sub g
and uh i said okay well how do we do
that
i i knew that t was the time at which
collapse would occur
and i thought that we would have to
relate that some way to something in the
brain like 40 hertz oscillations
back then gamma synchrony 40 hertz
oscillations was the big thing
so uh when you had coherent 40 hertz geg
you had consciousness that's
that's and regarding these oscillations
is it just that the neurons are firing
at the same time
40 000 times a second no this is 40
hertz just 40 times a second
but it's not firing it's not firing
actually that's that's one of the uh
that's one of the problems people
uh say that but neurons you take one
neuron
it's integrate and fire it's the basic
hodgkin huxley neuron
so you have the dendrites and soma that
receive inputs from the synapses
and and the story goes that
strictly by membrane potentials uh these
thresholds are integrated these
potentials are integrated to a threshold
at what was called the axon hillock
where the axon begins or now it's called
the axon initiation segment
and if if the threshold is met there'll
be a firing
and the axon would depolarize and
you get the signal down to the next
synapse whatever that may be
and uh because it was an all or none if
it fired it fired
that was considered the the the binary
the bit
the fundamental unit of firing but
actually
eeg comes mostly from local field
potentials which come from the dendrites
in the soma
from the integration phase from the
integrate and fire in the hodgkin huxley
not not the firing
but it's more convenient for ai and for
neuroscientists to consider
bits to consider firings to be the bits
it fits better with the computer uh
analogy and uh and so people say that
in fact christophe koch and crick and
coke
francis crick and christoph koch back
then in in 90 actually came out the idea
that 40 hertz was the
was the neural correlate of
consciousness but
they were they were also uh committed to
the idea that spikes
firings were they were the currency of
consciousness
so when it was realized that uh that it
was um
that that firings that eeg came from the
local field potentials on the dendritic
side
uh from integration not the firings they
dropped 40 hertz they said well it can't
be in other words they had to choose
between firings
and 40 hertz as the neural coral of
consciousness and they went with firings
and spikes and dropped the 40 hertz i
think that was
a big mistake but in any case it was it
was 40 yards but
so we were we were thinking well we had
to maintain the quantum coherence state
for 25 milliseconds to get 40 hertz 40
times a second
and in retrospect that was a mistake on
our part because um
that's way too long for a quantum state
we thought well you could do it
you know nature figured it out and so
forth but it was really
uh you don't need that it turns out
um to make the long well i'll i'll come
back to that point but
but going back to the uh to quantifying
this
by uh t equals h bar over e sub g or e
sub g equals
h bar over t the same thing to relate
the time
to the e sub g so what is the e sub g so
e sub g
is the amount of mass in superposition
the amount of mass
separated from itself and when that meat
reaches the threshold
at a time t or if you can sustain that
until time t you'll have a moment of
consciousness
the amount of mass of what well of
anything but in this case of
microtubules
of micro of tubulin and uh and that's
another
good question so uh if you start with it
with with a protein
it's got all these atoms and rings and
electrons and protons and
this and that so but all the mass is in
the nuclei
you know the electrons so basically the
the electrons
uh uh have all the the uh cool electron
dipole oscillations and quantum stuff
that anesthesia comes in and blocks and
that causes loss of consciousness
but if you just look at the electrons
the mass was too low to get a
significant e sub g
so you have to displace the nuclei to
get sufficient e sub g
the the electrons what a thousandth the
uh
the the the mass of a
of a nucleus for example so we said okay
we got to deal with the nuclei
but then the nuclei or okay we have to
deal with the superposition of a protein
so roger gave me this assignment he said
you can look at it three ways
you can look at the protein being
separated from itself
partially by let's say ten percent of
its mass
so uh it ten percent ten percent is just
an example right now or
he well that's when we use the
calculation okay because we're initially
we're thinking of a conformational
change open and close open and close
the difference what you're doing right
now with your hands is that the tubulin
flexing yes okay we thought there had to
be a conformational change
it turns out you don't need that but
that was the original thought
and the difference in the flux is about
10 so we calculated the
the e sub g uh of a protein separated
from itself by ten percent of its
diameter
and he said okay you do it that way and
he gave me this this formula these
formulas basically algebra
and which i was able to do and he said
we also have to do it at the level of
the nucleus take the atomic nucleus of
each atom
uh so you have an electron out here but
the nucleus is here
and the nucleus can be separated from
itself
by its diameter so instead of being one
sphere it'd be two spheres
literally next to each you have complete
separation so that gives a different
different type of equation than partial
separation so that was two so it was
the protein by 10 partial separation the
new
the
all those nuclei within the protein 110
000
uh atomic weight separated
by their diameter and the third way was
going even smaller
to the protons and neutrons the nucleons
separated from themselves so he gave me
the equations
and uh and i spent some time you know
doing the calculations
and came up with the result that
separation the level of the atomic
nuclei
was the dominant effect gave you the
highest energy and would
occur before the others so we knew so
we knew how to calculate for the
superposition
and then you just multiply that by the
number of nuclei and we get the
the uh the e sub g for a tubulin protein
yeah when you're talking about the
atomic nuclei is that
okay the proteins are made up of well
mostly carbon we use carbon
you know it's mostly carbon carbon
chemistry but you know there's
phosphorus there's oxygen there's other
stuff but
but basically we we used we calculated
based on carbon
because the vast majority of the nuclei
are carbon why do you want the energy to
be high
because t equals h bar over e so
high e would make a lower t and don't
you want the t to last for quite some
time
you do but you got to go with you know
with what nature gives you
and and the the dot the high energy is
going to be the dominant effect it's
going to happen
first so that's going to trigger the
collapse before the other effects you
know
if you avoided that it might collapse
from the the separation of the whole
protein or separation of the nucleons
but the separation of the nuclei is
going to happen first and and and that's
going to that's
what's going to you know rule the what's
going on so you had to deal with that
so that was the first thing we learned
so the next question was
okay let's say that's right uh how many
uh how many um
how many tubulins how many microtubules
uh would you need to have a
superposition
for t so what would the e sub g a number
of tubulins
be to have a t equal 25 milliseconds
which is what we thought probably needed
and it turns out it's a pretty small
number it's only like i forget
20 20 neurons worth if all the neurons
in one microtubule
if all the if all the microtubules in
one neuron were in superposition
you would only need and because t is a
long time
so it's a trade-off it's a long time so
uh you don't need
very much e sub g but you have to avoid
decoherence
for a long time but we weren't
considering that yet we're putting that
aside
so for 25 milliseconds you only needed a
few uh
like 20 neurons worth so we thought well
maybe only a fraction of the turbulence
are involved
but that seemed kind of that's seemed
kind of odd
um later we realized actually and
several people suggested this
to us that you know you don't really
need these the quantum state to last 25
milliseconds to have 25
millisecond events in the brain and much
later we came around to the
to the idea that the the quantum
superpositions
involve much more of the brain much more
tubulin
for a much shorter time so because it's
inversely related
so um basically for example if
uh if you say that there are uh
um 10 to the 10th uh
so there's about 10 bananas at 10 of the
eighth turbulence per neuron
and if if uh if you have the uh
the t not be 25 milliseconds but be
say 10 megahertz a tenth of a millionth
of a second
then you need a much larger amount of
tubulin
much larger number of microtubules much
larger proportion of the brain
is still small so for example for 10
megahertz for oscillation for these
quantum events to be happening 10
million times a second
you need about 10 to the minus fifth of
the total tubulins in the brain
which was uh billions and uh uh
well i forget millions and millions of
neurons
i have to go back and look it up but
it's it's a much more reasonable number
than just 20.
if i understand what you're saying is
that we need you know how some people
say we only use one percent of the brain
what you're suggesting that's probably
true actually for consciousness
but it's not the same one percent yes
this could be here and then it's here it
actually can quite literally move around
the brain
right so you may use only one percent at
one time but over
your lifetime or even maybe a day you're
using most of it if not all of it
right and if you were to use more that's
well if you were to use 100 that's
categorized as a seizure and it's not
actually
salutary well seizures are bad and
seizures are
when all the the spikes the firings are
coordinated
and that's not conscious so that's
that's uh that's a pathology that's
that's when the all the neurons are
firing it's unclear what's
actually happening in the integration
side uh
but i think yeah but but that's that's
not really the same thing but
but basically we did make a relationship
between the not between the fraction of
the brain the number of tubulins
involved
the the the frequency and the intensity
of experience
and we based that on on a couple things
extrapolated for example
uh meditators uh trained meditators have
really high eeg compared to uh normal
people
and uh and as a baseline or when they're
baseline and when they meditate both and
this was done in uh
richard davidson's lab i don't know 15
20 years ago
and the dalai lama sent his best
meditators over and they studied him
with eeg
and at baseline uh their i forgot the
frequent the baseline they were much
higher and when they meditated they were
like off the charts
as an aside what does he use to qualify
them as a
as the best meditators that was
whoever his choice okay i got it i got
it
i don't know we'll give him we'll give
him that he should know
so uh so based on that eeg gets gets
higher
and uh there are some other inklings of
that you know if
if you're in a car accident and the car
is spinning uh
supposedly the external world slows down
everything slows down
and that could be because you're having
more conscious moments per second
than you were before the accident
occurred and
great athletes like michael jordan said
when he's playing well
it's because the other team is in slow
motion and so
uh i recall i recall you saying this i
spoke to a neil seth i'm sure you've
heard of him yes i know neil yeah
i asked him about this about the time
slowing effects and if it is indeed a
real effect or if it's just your
perception of time slows down
and he said what's been done is you
measure people on bungee jumps
and you show them perhaps a clock and
they're not able to recall
milliseconds at a higher rate than
people who are not under the bungie
yeah you know i know that study that's
david eagleman's study
and it's it was kind of a it was like uh
i don't know i'm not sure i believe it i
don't think so just a few minor studies
that haven't decisively
made the case okay continue we don't
really know but
but it seems to me that consciousness
the the the intensity of experience is
related to the frequency of the events
that you're having
so if you're if you're excited uh if
you're in an altered state
if you're doing something you really
love uh
you're having more conscious moments per
second
if you can measure it but to you the
external world slows down
and when you're on psychedelics it seems
like the brain isn't
firing as much or using as many neurons
is that correct
that's a very good question yeah so
that's the study of
uh robin carhart harris from 2012
and he presented that at the tucson
conference
and uh amazing study um what they did
was
they they put people in an mri scanner
they also did eeg
so it works for mri but in the
in the mri scanner and in the eeg they
then gave them intravenous psilocybin
which is the active ingredient in magic
mushrooms psychedelic mushrooms
and then later you know they they had
them report what they were experiencing
at the time
they didn't ask them at the time because
and later they reported their experience
and they were all basically having a
psychedelic experience they're basically
all tripping
at the time and in the scanner they kind
of i think they expected their their
brains to
kind of light up like pinball machines
but they didn't
their brains look cold and dark like
they were unconscious almost comatose
and in the eeg they expected i'm not
sure what they expected but what they
got was almost flatline eeg
and it was it was paradoxical and
those debate those results are still
being debated what i think
and robin didn't like this idea and uh a
lot of people don't
but uh what i thought was that under
those circumstances
um consciousness is has
gone into the microtubule quantum states
almost completely and the membranes
which perform cognition
are violent are quiet silent you don't
need uh
you don't need uh energy um for the
membranes
you don't have to well you need what i'm
let me back up
what the brain needs energy for is to
maintain uh membrane potentials
the quantum the quantum microtubule
stuff is very low energy you don't need
much energy
so um if you're tripping and you don't
have to do anything
cognitive you don't have to drive a car
you have to talk to anybody
you're just laying there in your own
mind your membranes can be
can be can be quiet consciousness has
gone to a deeper level into the quantum
state
so you don't require energy for membrane
membrane potentials
for firing and uh you know by the same
token
you wouldn't want somebody in that
condition driving you home their
cognition
wouldn't be very good if they're if
they're deep into a quantum
consciousness state
so that was my explanation for why
people who are tripping
have low uh what
their brains appear to be silent and
dormant and their eeg is flat
it's because everything's gone to a
deeper level and if you get to that
level you find
much much faster and more active
activity
at the quantum level but the classical
level things are
on hold okay so let me make a layman
rudimentary
analogy let's imagine that what the eeg
is measuring
is the rate at which or the speed at
which you're moving about or a group of
people are moving about in a room let's
say this
and they measure at like five kilometers
per hour they're walking but what you're
saying is
when you're under an altered state of
consciousness it's like you're going
into a deeper room let's say the
basement
and now you're moving rapidly but the
eeg is showing a small amount because
it's only measuring what's in this room
is that somewhat correct yeah you kind
of go into the basement you go into the
uh
the underground where it's all quantum
and the energy is very very low
and you've do you've dissociated from
what's happening at the membrane
you've you've gone you've gone deep uh
into the i like to call it the quantum
underground is the actual
decoherence-free subspace where quantum
stuff stuff is happening in biology
but the membranes are on vacation the
membranes don't have to depolarize you
don't have to trigger firings
you're not doing anything actively other
than thinking other than being conscious
your body you you're not moving anything
you're not
doing performing any cognitive function
okay
and by the way um i'm gonna digress a
little bit but in some recent work i've
been doing
with allison watri at ucsd who studies
these cerebral organoids we're trying to
design experiments to see if cerebral
organoids
can be conscious we've kind of come to
the conclusion that
that there's cognition and there's
consciousness cognition
is you know stuff that we do uh that
could be conscious or not conscious
driving for example walking
sometimes you're walking and or i'm
walking my mind's wandering i'm
somewhere else
uh i'm technically paying attention but
uh to
the sidewalk and whatnot but i'm not
that conscious of it then all of a
sudden something happens
i see somebody or horn honks and then my
consciousness returns
to my cognition so cognition can be
either conscious or non-conscious
so we're thinking that we're the way
we're expressing now is that
consciousness is supervening
on cognition and kind of takes over
cognition and
when it needs to so you can be on
autopilot most of the time driving or
walking or
doing whatever without consciousness and
then suddenly you need it
and it shows up and supervenes on
cognition
is this the opposite of the prevailing
view that cognition supervenes on
consciousness rather than the other way
around
if that's the prevailing view yes it
would be is that what the prevailing
view is
no i'm well i'm asking you you know much
more i don't actually i've never
uh i've heard the term super venue it's
it it's a
it's a term in philosophy and but i
always thought it applied to
consciousness
supervising like and kind of taking over
cognition
it could go the other way around if you
know but no i think consciousness
supervenes on cognition
and in fact we can't measure
consciousness in the brain
or organoids or anything but what we
might be able to measure
is the effect of consciousness on
cognition because cognition
can be computable so go back to roger
rogers point about uh
consciously non-computable well
if you had something you could observe
in the brain that was computable
and then consciousness came in you would
you would see deviation
from computable behavior in
hodgkin-huxley neurons
and that's exactly what we're trying to
do in this study we're proposing
that is to look for it for for the
shadow of consciousness to look for
the shadow consciousness casts on
cognition deviation from
computable behavior in neurons and
hodgkin-huxley neurons for example
because of consciousness and to see if
that goes away with anesthesia
so anesthesia should make you more
computable
more automatic more autopilot-like
and we do see that type of behavior
under anesthesia without consciousness
so that's a way of looking at
consciousness by looking at the effect
it has on
cognition as another aside is there a
way of using
anesthesia to make a truth serum
you know uh pentethal was used for that
uh brevitol back in the old days and it
it
it just supposedly just the right amount
you could you could kind of uh uh
inhibit the just you can kind of inhibit
what is normally
uh inhibitory and and kind of just
disinhibit
the subject and get the truth out of it
i was never really impressed with that
and as an anesthesiologist i wasn't that
interested
in it because uh because you know well
we don't use pentathlon anymore but
propofol
and it's chewing light doses they are a
little disinhibited
and you just before they go to sleep
when they're waking up they may
say something uh uh
that's personal or you know but yeah
let's make it
through that as fast as possible and uh
so i'm not interested in using it using
that but but you can disinhibit somebody
at just the right dose
but it's very very transitory unless you
try to keep it their level
and then they're they're unconscious so
um
uh but you you mentioned psychedelics
before and when another experiment i
like to do is
i would predict well we predict to have
evidence that anesthesia slows and
dampens these oscillations
and that psychedelics would increase the
frequency and uh
we're going to try and look at that also
increase the frequency oscillations
increase the frequency of consciousness
which would account
at least in part for the psychedelic
experience
okay now as for collaborating with
penrose do you mind giving an example of
a recent one how does it look
what sorts of problems do you work on
let's take a recent example
well right now we're trying to finish a
chapter for a book
called quantum quantum mechanics and
consciousness edited by
shang gao i got this one from you uh
that's
our book that's that's a long story well
you were editors
yeah but but that was a mistake that's
not really our book
they used our name but we had nothing
well i i hope it's your book because it
took me quite a bit of time just to get
through a bit of it
is it any good i've never read it oh
okay
that's definitely not your book yeah
well
i was primarily interested in the
article by you and penrose okay and
that's it
i'll stand by that but um but uh
we're we're writing a chapter now for a
book uh by shanghai called quantum
mechanics and consciousness and
and dave chalmers has has an article and
a lot of people have articles
and uh um you know i was thrilled to
write another article
with roger but he's dif he's difficult
to work with
because he's very meticulous he's got
like 20 things going on and everything
has to be perfect so
to make a long story short the the
chapter is three years late
and the absolute drop dead deadline is
uh uh sunday this sunday and uh
my part i you know i keep working on but
i'm basically uh
waiting on his part and uh he's actually
putting in some new stuff
about retroactivity backward time
effects and uh
effect and uh and so it's worth waiting
for and i hope the uh
the editor feels that way also but um
uh so that and now we do it with email
we first started we did it with uh faxes
and uh i still somewhere have uh rolls
and rolls of fax paper with his original
artworks and drawings that i'm
trying to preserve and uh occasional
phone calls
and uh it was slow going when i first
started collaborating
uh with roger uh his wife vanessa said
uh you know i encourage you but you
should know
be prepared it'll be very slow going uh
everything has to be just right before
he signs off on it
and he's very meticulous and he's way
over committed so just be patient
and i'm glad he told me that she told me
that because it turned out
to be true in fact it led to
an interesting uh we had been working on
the original uh
article that i mentioned earlier and
calculating all this stuff
for about a year i didn't even have a
didn't have a manuscript
but in the meantime uh pat churchlin who
had been at that conference that roger
went to
um uh back at cambridge uh
and a grad student came out with kind of
a preemptive attack piece
in the journal of consciousness studies
attempting to refute our
ideas before we even published anything
is this tag mark and
that was later that was another uh bogus
uh attack well i'll come i'll come to
him uh
but um now this is pat churchlin and a
grad student rick rush
and uh um she uh
materialist reductionist
computationalist
and they spent the first part of their
article uh attacking the uh
the girdle's theorem and
non-computability in the second half
attacking microtubules
and uh so and they're really snotty
about it
and uh the the title of their article
you know roger's famous for a lot of
things including penrose tilings
tiling a plane with geometry and so the
title of their article was uh penrose's
toilings
or gaps in penrose's toilings that there
were gaps
because there are no gaps in his tilings
but there's toilings in terms of his
ideas
and the first gaps were about the
girdle's theorem that they attacked
the second was about microtubules well
let's give it to them that's a clever
title
it was a clever title and they also said
said for example that uh
the penrose hammer off hypothesis was no
better supported
than one in a gazillion
caterpillar with hookah hypotheses
a reference to uh alice in wonderland
that
uh this is a quite literally a pipe
dream pipe dream they're basically
saying we're
we're bsing everybody you know that's
basically what they were saying and they
were we're full of them
so that was pretty snotty and but it was
sufficiently snotty to uh
provoke roger into into responding
fully and the uh the editor the
publisher of the journal said you can
have
or you can reply on the next issue but
i'll need a manuscript in two weeks
and so i said oh my gosh you know it's
been a year we don't have a manuscript
how can we possibly do this in two weeks
well we got on the phone and roger said
i'll tell you what i can i can answer
all the girdle serum stuff
you answer all the microtubule stuff put
the two parts together
write a common abstract and i can do my
part in in two weeks i said i could do
my
my part in two weeks so we did and uh
the microtubule stuff was was pretty
easy actually
for example their main point what they
thought was their killer argument
was that uh there's a drug called
colchicine which is used in gout
gout is arthritis where immune cells go
into
joints like the big toe the great toe
and uh
and cause tremendous inflammation and
swelling and pain it's very
it's very painful and um
and yet uh when you take because it deep
polymerizes the microtubules and that
paralyzes the immune cells
from migrating into the joint so the
microtubules are depolymerized
and they said see microtubules are deep
polymerized and you don't people
who with gout who take colchicine don't
lose consciousness therefore
microtubules must be unnecessary for
consciousness
right but it doesn't cross the blood
brain it's just not
right coaching does not cross the
blood-brain barrier uh
number two it only affects microtubules
they're wrapped they're constantly
assembling and disassembling and those
in the brain don't
they're quite stable okay which is why
uh you can store memory in them
and i found a paper where somebody
actually injected colchicine
into the uh into the the brain of
animals and just wiped them out they
were demolished
so i answered that and uh there's some
other stuff and roger ants the girls
there
put an abstract together and uh we wrote
this paper uh
uh gaps what gaps response to aggression
that was our first paper in 95. and then
uh
next year we had two papers in 96 and
then
no papers until 2014 and then we
rehashed that as an
updated version in 2018 and uh
2016. and now this this paper which uh
we're writing uh
right now so maybe half a dozen papers
over
20 years but they've all been good
now going to this backward time right
aspect
i heard you mention libits experiments
and that they don't necessarily show a
lack of free will
but perhaps the free will propagates
backward in time now can you explain
that
well libbet did these experiments in uh
well he did two sets of experiments the
first
set of experiments that roger wrote
about in his uh book the emperor's new
mind
uh were sensory experiments where he had
people uh
uh under in neurosurgery he worked with
a neurosurgeon named bertram
uh epstein who by the way was the the
husband
of uh diane sorry bertram feinstein
who was the husband of dianne feinstein
the the governor
sorry the senator from california she's
still around he passed away years ago
but he was a neurosurgeon and live at
work with him
and so he had patients that he did uh
neurosurgery on well awake
so he would drill a hole and numb it up
with local anesthetic and once you get
into the brain you can operate on the
brain
it doesn't hurt but you you make you
numb up the hole
and you can access the brain and for
example for the
the for the finger on the opposite hand
so
libya did experiments like he would
stimulate the finger and record from the
brain
and stimulate the the uh the brain
and uh and then uh
see uh when the when the subject
was conscious of feeling the finger
so um you would expect or i would expect
not knowing anything beforehand that if
you stimulate the brain you feel it
immediately
if you stimulate the finger it would be
a delay because it had to get to the
brain
well if you stimulate the finger there
is a delay but it's only 30 milliseconds
evoke potential so it's pretty fast but
if you stimulate the brain directly
you need to have ongoing activity and it
takes about a half a second 500
milliseconds
because you don't get the evoked
potential but if it continues for 500
milliseconds
you do feel it at 30 milliseconds what's
this evoked potential
okay so if you stimulate the finger the
signal you get a spike that's the evoked
potential
if you stimulate it here you don't get
the evoked potential you just get
you know ongoing activity looks like
gamma but if you do it for half a second
the patient subject has the conscious
experience at the time of the evoked
potential
30 milliseconds so somehow at 30
milliseconds the brain
knows whether or not there's going to be
500 milliseconds of ongoing activity
afterwards
if there is he or she reports it at 30
milliseconds
that's interesting okay if there isn't
then he or she does
and so libbet concluded that there was a
signal going backwards in time
from the time of the uh what he called
neuronal adequacy
and then send this information back
we're in time now roger wrote about this
in emperor's neuron because
um that hap that can happen in quantum
physics
which is temporarily non-local is this
related to the subcutaneous rabbit
have you heard of that were you someone
yes but this is related to that yes
and also the color five phenomenon where
the color bounces back and forth and
it goes from uh red to blue and you go
red blue red blue and you can guess then
it goes red red
and you know you're not fooled and
that's because you seem to know what's
going on and the cutaneous rabbits the
the same thing i actually wrote a wrote
a chapter about i can send it to you
about
about all this well i've written uh
several actually about it and
and all those can be accounted for
by you somehow know know what's coming
and
this is very important because um if you
and i are talking and you ask me a
question
and if someone were measuring the
activity in my brain
for what you said it'll happen and say
300 to 500 milliseconds after
they get to my ears but i will have
responded to you at 100 milliseconds
this is very very standard neuroscience
what neuroscience says
about that is that i respond
non-consciously
and have a false illusion of answering
consciously after the fact
the consciousness is epi phenomenal my
cognitive autopilot non-conscious self
answers you and then a little later my
conscious self says oh i said that
you know i'm in control and it means
that consciousness is epi phenomenal
and illusion illusory that's what dennis
says
that's what all you know all the big of
the big name philosophers say
unless they have some way to to weasel
out of it
and but if you have backward time it
means that you can have
you can you can do all that and you can
still respond consciously in real time
has dennett ever publicly commented
specifically on yours or penrose's
theories
no and he won't in fact uh i've argued
with him at several meetings and all he
does is yell at me without listening to
what i'm saying
and uh in fact what do you think that is
because he doesn't know anything about
the brain he doesn't know the damn thing
about the brain he admits it he doesn't
know a neuron from all the ground
and so all these you know he knows
computers and that's how computers work
and unfortunately that's true about
about a lot of a lot of people
so uh we actually uh my colleague tom
bever is
putting a course to get we're putting a
course together on conscious studies and
and tom asked dan dana whom he knows
some years ago if he would and he just
blew him off so he's not interested and
uh
you know they have their position they
don't want to be bothered with the facts
i've been arguing with dan for years and
uh
you can't argue with the guy you know
what do you disagree with penrose on
could be minor it could be metaphysical
uh i'm not sure i agree but i
i would say that i uh i'm not saying i
disagree necessarily but i
i i tend to go further than he does in
certain things like
you know the spiritual implications of
of his whole
platonic values and universal
consciousness
that he does he just doesn't he just
won't talk about it he says i don't find
it useful to talk about
uh and uh the backward time effect he's
still a little bit reluctant to go as
far as i go
but um uh
[Music]
stuff about anesthesia he's you know he
i think that once i've explained what
i'm trying to i kind of get ahead of
myself in saying things and then once i
i kind of backfill on what i was trying
to say he tends to go that's happened in
our recent
in our recent paper for example um i'll
give you an example um
i we're talking about the hodgkin-huxley
neuron and you integrate and fire
and it's and um that is computable
when the threshold is met firing happens
but if you put electrodes and this was
done in 2006 by non-dorfdol in germany
they put electrodes in
in pyramidal cells of awake cats and
what they fi
and what they find so presumably they're
conscious they find that there's a
tremendous variability
from from firing to firing so the
threshold is changing something
other than the membrane potential than
the input so something other
than the measurable inputs that are
triggering the firing which
controls behavior and uh uh
they that sounds groundbreaking because
usually it's thought of as
you just input a certain voltage
electric field and then it will
fire correct the synaptic inputs come in
they change the voltage on the membrane
of the dendrites in the soma
and when that uh accumulated integrated
membrane potential
gets to the exon initiation segment it's
compared to a threshold
and if the threshold is met firing
occurs that's the standard
hodgkin-huxley neuron
but in a neuron in an awake animal
that firing threshold is highly variable
there's some other factor
and so i started calling that a
non-computable factor
and uh roger uh didn't understand what i
was trying
you you say no non-computability has to
do something deep in quantum physics
and i was saying yes i i know and but it
has to come into the brain somewhere
and so that's where i thought it was
coming in so uh
he's come up he's come around to that
now and we're going to include that in
our
our paper so basically you can measure
non-computability in neurons
and uh that's the d as a as a deviation
from hodgkin-huxley
uh behavior and uh which is also what i
was saying before deviation from
from cognitive uh autopilot function
because the hodgkin huxley behavior
would be fine for walking down the
street doing things that don't require
you know non-computable consciousness or
intuition insight
that platonic values uh values that sort
of thing
so um i think he's coming here he's
seeing
i'm trying to put his non-computability
into the brain specifically at the end
of integration
in pyramidal neurons where at the end of
this orchestrated period
and reduction and that can uh change the
firing
depending on your conscious thoughts so
rather than
responding reflexively to something or
somebody you think about it or you have
a conscious
uh thought or intuition or feeling well
i just lit a feeling i better do
something different
you know i don't want to do that i'm not
sure why but so it's
intuition it's inside its creativity
which are things comes out of this
non-computability
and i think it manifests in terms of
altering the firing capability of these
neurons
okay i'm going to take a look at some of
the questions that we have here
actually for now you know this podcast
or this series
has a tendency to get somewhat technical
so
i thought how about this time instead of
leaving it unexplained how about i
or you try to explain some of these
abstracts and
seemingly inscrutable terminologies and
then perhaps someone can understand
a full quote and maybe by understanding
the parts they can understand it as a
whole
i'm basically taking quotes from your
article so here's one
okay how would microtubule quantum
computations which are isolated from the
environment
still interact with that environment for
input and output
one possibility is that orc or suggests
that
perhaps phases of isolated quantum
computing alternate with phases of
classical environmental interaction
eg at gamma synchrony isolated from the
environment do you mind explaining that
concept
for people well uh for quantum devices
and technology
have to be isolated from interaction
with the environment which is thought to
be random
and noisy and to do that they do things
at absolute near absolute zero
temperature to avoid any thermal
oscillations
so in biology we think that inside the
tubulins
in the high resonance groups um
you have a uh yeah that's one you'll
have to explain to pi resonance so why
don't we go to that first
all right so let me back up so the basic
uh molecule in living systems
uh is the the organic ring the benzene
ring
or the phenyl ring so you have six
carbons in a hexagon
and each carbon has in pure benzene each
carbon has one hydrogen
and that leaves two more bonds uh so one
bond goes to
uh three more bonds per for carbon one
go
one each goes to the two neighboring
carbons and you have an extra electro
you have an extra bond so you have three
extra electrons
in a carbon ring so what do they do they
form these delocalized clouds above and
below the carbon ring
and this is a quantum area it's nonpolar
so there's no charge um but it's neutral
because the the positive charge is in
the is a nuclei
so you have this electron cloud above
and below and it's a quantum
entity it takes up space small space
volume and if you put two of these
together
the the electron cloud in one the
electro negativity will repel the
electrons over here
so you get a dipole and you get a an
induced dipole
and there's a dipole in this one and
there's a dipole in this one
and this one induces this one and then
this one induces back so you get an
oscillation of these dipoles
when you say oscillation in the dipole
you mean oscillation in the charge so
that it's more positive on one side than
the negative and it switches or what the
net charge is
is is neutral but the dipole means
you're pushing
in in each cloud the electrons tend to
migrate to one side or the other
depending on what's near them so if
there's another cloud near them they're
both neutral
the electrons in one are going to repel
the other one so they tend to do this
they tend to oscillate
and that's just two of them now one of
them doesn't do that
and i should also say that if you get a
bunch of benzene and put them together
if they're not spaced properly they're
flammable that's gasoline
but if if you put them so they're spaced
in a geometric array
for example in a planar sheet that's
graphene and graphene has a lot of
quantum properties
but if you put them in a lattice where
there's space they can oscillate and
that's basically frolic coherence
so they're in a nonpolar region they're
isolated from the environment
but the question was okay let's say you
have that in this isolated environment
how do you communicate input and output
with the outside world
and uh that's a very good question and
our answer to that
came from a science fiction book by a
guy named paul benioff
who was one of the inventors of quantum
computers
deutsche benioff and i forget who
uh feynman are generally uh
credited with you know inventing the
concept upon computers
and uh benioff uh was a roger knew
and actually spoke at our 2003 quantum
mind conference
i had written a sci-fi book and he
talked about it in his talk
and he had a quantum computer robot and
it went through phases of quantum and
then collapsed to the
answer and that would communicate with
the environment
and during that phase you get inputs so
you get
output input then quantum again process
collapse
so the alternating phases of quantum and
classical quantum classical
and during the classical uh you'd have
interaction with the
both uh output and input now when we
said that for 40 hertz
uh i would change it now to say the same
thing happens
at say 10 megahertz because we think the
orca war events are happening much
faster
so uh after each event uh you're in the
classical phase
you you uh express the outputs and that
can trigger the neuron to fire or do
whatever
and receive inputs then you go back into
the quantum phase so you're alternating
between quantum and classical phases
roughly 10 million times a second
okay there's a hydrophobic property of
the benzene rings i believe
hydrophobic non-po nonpolar right
there's no charge so let's explain
those terms hydrophobic why is that
important and then non-polar they're
pretty much the same thing actually
hydrophobic means
water aversive so no water water is
polar
so basically think of it think of the
the brain or the body as a bunch of
different solubility compartments if
you're an anesthesiologist or
a pharmacologist or giving drugs to a
patient
you'd be you'd need to know uh where in
the body of the drug is going to go
and if it's polar if it's charged then
it's going to be very soluble in water
and blood and tend to go to charged
surfaces like receptors on the surfaces
of
neurons and so forth if however you're
giving a drug like an anesthetic which
is non-polar
which is lipid-like oil-like
it doesn't like to be in water it's very
insoluble so it traverses the blood
quickly and goes to fat
membranes and proteins that have these
non-polar regions inside of them and
that's where
that's where it goes to very quickly and
that's that's where it acts
and in the non-polar regions uh is where
the quantum stuff can happen
without being exposed to at least the
polar charges
so you've reduced the the degrees of
freedom
and created what uh is called in the
quantum computing business a
decoherence-free subspace temporarily
where you can do quantum stuff without
without getting messed up by the
environment by the
classical environment okay forgive me if
i'm misunderstanding this but there's a
the microtubule has three layers if i
remember correctly there's a water
tube inside and then there's the tubulin
on the outside i've only read about the
a lattice so i don't know much about the
b
lattice and then there's apparently
another layer i just saw
anarban right okay enervan
give a talk on this but i don't know
much about what's going on the outer
layer so is compu is quantum computation
happening on the layer with the tubulin
or is it inside
where the water is okay so when you say
inside so micro tubes are hollow tubes
so you have an outside which is this
charge is coming out and it's basically
water
around it then you have the wall of the
microtubule
which is about uh four nanometers thick
it can be very long but four ma and then
you have the inner core
which is 15 nanometers of again water
ordered water and then you have the
other wall so you have a house water
huh well the water in the water and eye
there's also ions
in in the interior of the microtubule
may be completely ordered
because you have charges coming out from
the in
from the inside part of the tubulin and
then more ordered water more ordered
water and
the the water may become part of the
quantum state in that
uh that's okay that's another another uh
can of worms yeah yeah in fact uh i
co-authored a paper in 94.95 about
the uh about quantum states in the water
but in uh and that may be true but but
we think it's
originating in the nonpolar insi
nonpolarization inside the wall of the
microtubule
uh where it's sheltered from the water
either on the outside of the microtubule
on the inside of the microtubule
in the nonpolar regions which is exactly
where anesthetics go
and uh so we've coined this term the
quantum underground where anesthesia
goes the anesthetic nonpolar molecules
go and reside to block consciousness and
essentially affect
very little else the brain is still
active under anesthesia and all it's all
that's gone really is consciousness
when someone has alzheimer's it affects
the tau proteins correct
child proteins are microtubule
associated proteins and uh the top
proteins uh
basically microtubules disassemble and
become unstable that's i think that's a
big part problem with alzheimer's
disease
and the towel tau binding at specific
places on the microtubules
can encode memory and uh and when
the microtubules disassemble whether the
towel falls off first
and then that destabilizes the
microtubules or the microtubules
destabilize
and then the towel falls off you lose
the microtubules you lose synapses
because the microtubules make synapses
you lose the tau memory function on the
microtubules
so it's all bad and i've
been wanting to do a study using
ultrasound into the brain
which we think can re-polymerize
microtubules and we've been
we've been studying my ultrasound of the
brain for a while and showing that it
it can enhance mood and is safe
and we're gearing up to do a study on
alzheimer's and dementia
can you use this to form a treatment for
alzheimer's
that is let's say you hope sorry to the
stability of tau it helps
well it's the stability of the
microtubules i think uh
the tau is a microtubule associated
protein right everybody gets worked up
about tau they can measure talent spinal
fluid
they can do this but they're not they're
not thinking about what the tau
does when it's not messed up when it's
doing its you know it's functioning
properly
and what it is is a microtubule
associated protein
and and and sits on microtubule lattices
uh at specific locations which seems to
to
to code for uh delivery of synaptic
uh cargo to to synapses so it actually
plays a role that's lost in alzheimer's
okay you mentioned that there's some
self-similar property of conductance at
the different levels of scales
now sorry i just copy this down i don't
know if this is an exact quote
what does that mean that there's
self-similar properties of conductance
at different levels
so honorable bonjour party whom you
mentioned several times who is a good
friend of mine
uh has done amazing work on microtubules
over the years going back
from 2009 he published in 2013 2014 and
then more recently
and basically he used yeah there you go
uh that image has gotten around a lot um
and basically for the audience in case
they can't see this
is one of the slides i was going to ask
you to explain at some point but we can
do that after
it's three low i haven't memorized
actually on the left you have
three levels of scale and then uh you
use different types of uh
uh nanopros scanning tunneling
microscopes atomic force electrodes this
and that and
uh so you're putting electrodes on a
microtubule now normally microtubule
all proteins are are insulators they
don't conduct very well
what honor bond did was he he put
electrodes and then he swept
and then he stimulated with alternating
current and he swept the current from
zero
up to i i forget how high terror
megahertz
oh okay you're right and he found at
certain frequencies that you would get
conducted
at certain critical frequencies
microtubules would be would conduct
would be would would have the
resonances or conductances in a triplet
of triplet patterns
and these triplet of triplet patterns
repeated about every
not quite every three orders of
magnitude uh i see what you're saying i
see what you're saying
okay and so what is the significance of
it resonating what does that mean when
it resonates so you're sending it an ac
current
yeah okay now is that much like when you
put water in the microwave and the water
heats up
now i keep water out of this water water
is the enemy here there may be uh
because it's polar these electrodes are
attached directly to the microtubule
so i think the conductance is happening
through the the pi
resonance inside the uh and and
inside the wall of the microtubule in
this helical pathway uh he's measuring
conductance
i see yeah and the the uh and the at
certain frequencies the microtubules
conducted
conducted highly conductive so what is
the significance of this it's
interesting
geometrically visually but what is well
it's a it's he called it ballistic
conductance he couldn't prove quantum
because there's a classical interface
between the electron electrode and the
surface of the microtubule
but within the you know within the the
pi resonance
it was probably something like
superconductivity or some kind of
quantum state
frolic resident or something like that
so it's a quantum state at critical
resonance frequencies that
have something to do with the
vibrational frequencies of the
microtubules
is there a way to use anesthesia to test
the consciousness of someone so for
example you mentioned there
are these buddhist monks who claim to
have a higher level of consciousness
so can you take someone who has a lower
level of consciousness give them a
certain amount of anesthesia
see how much does it take to put them
asleep
and then see if you need more to put
someone who claims to be higher in
consciousness
i don't think it's because i'm not sure
there'd be an effect
actually i don't think you know i don't
think a uh
well i don't know whether a a meditator
or a genius or some
extraordinary person requires any more
anesthesia than anybody else i i don't
know that it could be but
that would seem to be you know trying to
split hairs at a level where
you know i'm more interested in knowing
how anesthesia works on anybody or
an animal or an organoid or a mouse or
any human
and we still don't know that i mean
that's a very good question you asked
but
it's kind of like we're not there yet to
you now we want to know how it works on
anybody
much less you know uh the dalai lama or
something like that
what are frolic resonances frolic
coherences are fully resonant follow
coherences
what i talked about before where you
have these nonpolar dipoles that
oscillate
and they couple to the mechanical
vibration
also the key here is that everybody says
the brain is too warm wet and noisy for
for quantum effects so warm means it's
too hot
and noisy also means it's too hot but if
you have a
geometrical lattice with with mechanical
vibrational resonances
the heat's going to pump it so it's
going to have these oscillations that
are coherent
so you couple the quantum coherence the
mechanical parent
that's why you're saying it was like a
laser yes exactly
okay is computation happening at the
level of glial cells or is it just the
pyramidal neurons
good question uh glial cells have a lot
of microtubules all cells have even
plant cells have microtubules
the the pyramidal cells uh
so what's different about microtubules
in in neurons in general is that okay
let me back up you know take any cell at
all
and uh uh an amoeba or or any cell
you can the microtubules are going to
radiate out from the central part of the
cell like spokes of a wheel
they're going to be continuous because
you want their structural support
and they're gonna they have the same
polarity they have a plus end and a
minus set
so they're all unipolar and radial
uh yeah but that's for pyramidal right
yeah so pyramidal they're interrupted
and of mixed polarity so you have one
going here one going
going here and uh and um
if if you if you wanted them there for
structural support like the
skeleton of your body you wouldn't have
them broken and interrupted
okay and why would you have them mixed
polarity up and down
and that's been a big mystery and what
we what roger and i think is that
that if you have two microtubules in
mixed polarity next to each other and
they're in a common voltage
they're gonna have slightly different
frequency resonant frequencies and
that's going to give rise to beat
frequencies
so going back to what i said before
about you know eventually when i
and and what you said about repeating at
different frequency ranges
we want to get the cell similar patterns
from the terahertz gigahertz megahertz
kilohertz
and hertz which is eeg so the eeg
may be kind of a a snapshot at a very
slow
low frequency of what's happening at
kilohertz uh megahertz gigahertz and
terahertz
so it's all kind of more like music than
computation is another way of putting it
when you have resonances and
and harmonics and interference beats
like in music
i see at the bottom of this there are
this is just for the people who are
watching all over yeah so what are these
frequencies indicating
is it that same energon yeah yeah that
goes along with that
yeah yeah and then i try to put it in a
schematic to show what's happening at
each level
does this mean that potentially quantum
computers can be
conscious they would have to collapse by
roger's mechanism and right now quantum
computers
are built at uh near near absolute zero
and um
uh they collapse because somebody makes
a measurement which
this is randomness so it's presently
constituted no
however uh uh my friend hart mcnevin who
is the head of uh
google google's quantum ai
uh roger and i visited there uh a year
or so ago
and uh we were talking about this
and uh they they had uh discovered some
anomalies
in their quantum computing when it
seemed to be uh collapsing prematurely
and uh i had and hartman told me that i
said well are you sure your client care
is not conscious
you know it's having the roger's
objective reduction and he said oh my
god i hope not
because that would have created a public
relations
issue so this one of his people gave a
seminar and
showed you know tons and tons of
equations that i didn't understand
and concluded that no it wasn't
objective reduction
and their quantum computer wasn't
conscious
i'm not sure i understood but they at
least they at least thought about it
however i think it is possible to have a
conscious
quantum computer if you built it out of
something like uh graphene or fullerenes
that's
that's much more biological and did it
at warm temperature
and pumped it to get to get coherence
which would be basically building
something like a microtubule in an
artificial sense
i i you know that's it's not something i
want to do because i i'm not
technological but
i think it that is possible that may be
the future of
consciousness in you know in vitro if
you want to have a conscious computer
that'd be the way to do it
in the brain i believe it's topological
qubits
the topological yes so in the in the uh
in uh in the atlanta package
cutting off just one second do you mind
repeating that because as far as i don't
think google is pursuing topological
qubits but i know microsoft is
so if anyone has a chance of producing a
conscious computer would
it would be them but i'm not sure if
topological qubits are required or if
it's just because
of the brain needing some area
correcting and topological qubits seem
to be
resistant to that right and i have to be
careful here because roger
this is where another uh where roger and
i don't don't agree
and i'm not sure it's because i'm not
explaining uh
i think properly or he's smarter than me
and knows i'm wrong
before i even get there uh but
what happened was uh this goes back to
the late 90s roger invited me to the uh
to the royal society meeting on uh on
quantum information which was
right when all the entanglement stuff
was coming out really exciting time we
had all these uh
super smart young physicists talking
about entanglement over
hundreds of miles and this and that and
um you know i mean the aspect experiment
proving entanglement didn't happen until
86.
so 10 10 or 12 years later you know a
lot of it happened and they were
talking about this technology and we had
a talk by uh
uh john preschool of caltech and he
showed a
a a lattice for a quantum computer which
was orthogonal
where he had the quantum computations
running in one direction
kind of up and down and he had the
quantum air correction running
sideways so they were intersecting and
the quantum merit correction would would
correct the
what was happening on on the vertical
and uh
i kind of woke up from from dozing
because i
they had lost me a hexagonal lattice
like thinking on microtubule
well sure why not where you have it
going this way so
on the coffee break i was talking with
roger about it and he said wouldn't it
be interesting if the fibonacci pathways
were some kind of topological qubit and
but for him topology means like you know
the
the coffee cop uh has a
topology because of this and it has a
whole another meeting that that i wasn't
catching on to so uh i don't want to
talk about
so now i just call them helical
geometric pathways
but i think they could be topological in
a sense
and if you had them in a right because
in a microtubule if you have a
the helical pathway it's much more
stable from a quantum standpoint
because if for example one individual
tubulin gets out of whack it's going to
be pulled back into quantum coherence by
the others
so i think these helical geometric
pathways whether you call them
topological or not might be there might
be a way to go for quantum computing
in some kind of material it doesn't need
to be absolutely cold
is there something specific about the
lattice that's conducive to quantum
computing
or consciousness because i know that
penrose has done some work on the
tilings which are aperiodic which are
not tilings
well they're not periodic tilings i
don't know about the relationship
between periodic and aperiodic
i don't know if penrose was using those
tilings to demonstrate that well we can
do something that's non-computational
that was it or if it
has some other implication for
consciousness
good question i'm not sure actually i've
kind of asked him that myself
and and uh i get the feeling i'm not
even close to being able to
figure out what he's saying on that so i
can't really answer that
but the helical pathways i think
are very useful because they avoid
de-coherence and help us in other ways
why is it that iit says that
consciousness occurs at the back of the
brain but then the global neuronal
workspace theory says that
occurs at the front and where does your
theory
say it takes place
in pyramidal cells so the cortex has six
layers
the cortex covers well you know the
whole not the cerebellum but
everything else is on top and it's six
layers
and uh so when uh information comes in
it goes to layer
uh five well it winds up in layer five
it goes to four
and then from four goes one two three
and six and one two three and six
converge on layer five
and layer five is the pyramidal
pyramidal neurons they have these huge
cone-shaped cell bodies they call them
pyramids because
they look pure but actually they're
they're cone-shaped
and they're enormous compared to other
neurons
and they they have
the biggest array of mixed polarity
interrupted microtubules anywhere
and their basal or dendrites are
continuous and this
so they form one continuous sheet over
the whole cortex
and they are the and their outputs uh
illicit behavior and their apical
dendrites give rise to eeg
so i think consciousness can happen in
in
i think it could happen in anything
really if
but it may be proto-conscious if it
doesn't have information but the most
likely place in the brain would be among
the pyramidal neurons
of layer five throughout the whole
cortex with lateral connections
and i think consciousness can actually
move around within it
so if you're having an auditory
sensation it's an auditory cortex
visual it's in the visual cortex and
other other areas are related
prefrontal cortex i mean um
with with uh there the whole brain there
are three
you know it goes in three ways from
thalamus to primary cortex primary
cortex to the front of the brain
front of the brain elsewhere and it's
that third wave elsewhere
that seems to correlate with
consciousness because that's the only
way that's affected by anesthesia
now how about how that fits with gnw and
iit and uh
higher order theory and recursive
processing all the other theories
i'm not sure and i know that in the
templeton
program on accelerating research and
consciousness there's a
five million dollar study uh front of
the brain versus
back of the brain iit versus uh global
neuronal workspace
and i'm not sure what that's going to
prove actually because i think under
different circumstances consciousness
can be anywhere in the brain
but we'll find out we're part of that
program too but we're we're much more uh
uh focused on looking at effects of
anesthesia on quantum vibrations and
microtubules
and if we don't see that we're we'll
we'll be falsified so we're
we're putting their money where our
mouth is i'm not sure if this other
study will prove anything but we'll see
i actually i i've talked and read a lot
about
iit and the more i hear about those i
i don't really understand it i know it's
it's some measure of integration
but they say that it can happen at any
level so i asked christoph and julia
well what happens if
if you measure microtubules in uh if you
measure phi in microtubules
they said yeah it could be extremely
high there so that's well how do you
measure it
and they would they they couldn't say
how you would measure it i said what if
we get these quantum vibrations and
microtubules
could you apply and see if that that is
phi and they they wouldn't answer that
either so
uh i don't know actually and i think all
those other theories can be
more or less correct they're all at the
level of neurons although
ihds that can happen at any level but
they really focus on neurons
they could all be happening and then but
still need or happening at a deeper
level
so they're all basically uh
are cognitive architectures that may or
may not have anything to do with
consciousness
of course i'm yeah i'm skeptical i'm the
enemy according to them
and uh but i think that you need to go
to a deeper level into the quantum
economic realm do you feel like anyone
else has a scientific theory that
confronts the hard problem or something
that's posed as rigorous even
something slightly rigorous that could
be philosophical i think uh
i think our theory is head and shoulders
above any other theory in that regard in
terms of rigor or even approaching the
heart problem
i mean everybody else basically says
it's an emergent phenomenon at a
critical level of something
complexity some non-linear function that
has not yet been defined maybe it's five
but what is phi we don't really know
so i'm pretty i'm pretty uh dubious
about that i think uh
you know we're we're way farther out on
a limb
we're much easier to falsify than any
other theory
and that's both good and bad it's bad
because we could be falsified but it's
good that we have a specific theory
you know if it can't be falsified then
it's not a theory what are some ways of
falsifying it
well the what i just said we're we're in
this program now we're
starting experiments very soon uh so the
way they showed
the way they showed quantum coherence
quantum effects in photosynthesis
protein is take a this protein
and do what's called 2d electron
spectroscopy where you put
i think three laser beams in and get two
laser beams out
and if there's a or two emission two uh
emissions from it and if there's a
quantum superposition
in the protein then you get a sawtooth
interference a set of of interference
peaks coming out
and that is indicative that there's a
quantum superposition in the protein
so that was done with an fmo protein of
about 25 kilograms
and we'll be trying it at tubulin which
is 110 kilodollars 110
000. what's a kilodown kill adult
uh uh that's the united st
okay okay it's 110 the molecular the
molecular weight
is uh her atomic weight is 110 000. so
uh if you count up all the uh protons
and neutrons so it has i don't know how
many atoms out of that
but um uh
that's uh uh if the tubulin is four
times the size of the protein they
previously measured on is what i'm
trying to say
so it's it's a it's a step up and the
guy doing it is greg scholes who did
some of the original work in the
photosynthesis protein he's an expert in
this
so he thinks he can do it and there's
some tricks involved and if we see that
if we see that quantum interference at
room temperature
in a in a tubulin protein we'll then
attempt to anesthetize and see if it
goes away
proportional to the potency of the
anesthetic and we'd like to also give it
psychedelics and see if it increases ah
speaking of psychedelics you mentioned
that
well i'm not sure if it was you but
there's an indole group and they
interact with the benzene in some manner
uh an indole has a benzene and a
five-sided ring
combined it's a fuse it's fused so it's
found in tryptophan the amino acid
it's found in most of the psychedelics
you have this indoor ring
uh it's amazing actually the the the
neurotransmitters like serotonin and
dopamine
and the psychedelics all have these same
pi resonance groups that
that are conducive to quantum effects i
don't know if you've heard of this
thought i think you have because i think
i got it from you there's a thought
experiment by coke
called i don't know what to call it
other than binocular rivalry
and i'm not sure if it has implications
for your theory or implications for some
other theory but do you mind outlining
what that is
and then what your thoughts are on it
yeah well actually uh
it was done by nico slogathetis
where you present different images to
different to the two eyes
uh so one eye sings one scene one eyes
seeing the other thing
uh the other way to think of it is the
neck or cube
where you see in the foreground of the
background it shifts back and forth
or the the the vase and the face and
that sort of thing
there's two different perceptions but if
you if you put the two different things
you have a conscious perception of one
and then it switches to the other that
switches back and forth
and um uh i would say that you have a
superposition of both and it collapses
to one
and then it collapses to the other so i
have a you know that's that'd be our
explanation and my explanation for that
let's get to penrose and his explanation
as to how consciousness arises so
there's a superposition at a quantum
level and when it collapses
that is a small proto-consciousness
moment and somehow that consciousness
moment
is either influenced by or accesses
platonic forms
yes although yes uh well if it's
happening if it's proto-conscious
happening here there and everywhere
it's gonna have very little effect it's
gonna be
it's not going to be affected very much
by these platonic forms
which uh are kind of preferred states in
and uh in our in our paper roger came up
with the name of the equations that
actually govern this but i
i forget what they are at the moment um
but you need a you need a pretty
organized or orchestrated uh
superposition for that effect to be
significant yes that's the idea that
it's not random
like as it would be in measurement or
de-coherence but there's some influence
due to these
platonic testosterone preferred states
and therefore if you're mindful it'd be
like what we call intuition or
creativity or insight or
hunch or stroke of genius or
the way of the dao or divine guidance or
you know however you want to put it
speaking of stroke of genius the part of
your theory and penrose's theory that i
like
the most is not just the ingenuity of it
but the fa and
so for example you fold in multiple
mysteries like
how does one integrate quantum theory
with gravity and so on
but and by the way let me just
say we're criticized by i don't want to
interrupt your train of thought because
i want to hear
you you're going to ask me yeah it's a
compliment so
but but you know when you criticized uh
for
you know well people really chalmers has
ridiculed us and and
stephen pinker said well quantum theory
is one mystery consciousness
maybe they're the same mystery ha ha
well damn it maybe they are
and outcomes razor would suggest that
the minimization of mysteries is a good
thing i mean
dave chambers a good friend of mine
ridiculed us by saying oh they're just
invoking the mythical
minimization law of minimization of
mysteries but if you if you believe in
occam's razors
outcomes razor you know one explanation
for several mysteries is a good thing
and when i hear that i'm reminded of a
talk by tegmark
and you where you were both critiquing
one another and tegmark said hey
maybe consciousness is explained in the
same way that we thought there were
different laws for
billiard balls than the moon and it
turned out to be one law well you can
use that same
logic to suggest that quantum mechanics
has something to do with consciousness
in the same way
okay anyway what i like about your
theory yours and penrose is not just the
fact that it's creative and inventive
but
there's a gallantry there's an endurance
that you have to go against the
prevailing norms
and to take
criticism for years that you're a
crackpot and so on
and to me that
that's not easy that's
most people would consciously buckle or
unconsciously
so that is some i can't convey in words
how difficult that is
and that i actually find commendable
well thank you
thank you you know uh roger's just above
it all
and uh for my you know but although he's
sensitive and he doesn't like being
criticized but
but i think he's he's operating on a
higher level than
the rest of us so for him it's just well
they'll they'll figure it out eventually
my perspective about being criticized
and yeah it hurts um
but um you know i'm i i don't need
grants
i don't need to go and get grants to
fund my livelihood
so i don't need to follow somebody
else's idea
of what's important to put food on the
table
i you know i make my living as an
anesthesiologist i'm an academic so i i
do research and so forth
but my livelihood doesn't depend i
follow my nose i follow my intuition
it's it's more of a i hate to say it's a
hobby because that
sounds demeaning because it's very
important to me
um but why is it so important
it's the most interesting question in
the world i mean it's uh
it's it's it's what i do you know
if i were if my hobby were well i used
to ski a lot if it was skiing
it what i love that you just want to go
out and ski and it's what i enjoy doing
and you know it's fun and it's gotten me
to see the world i met people like roger
and you and
countless other people and been uh all
over the world you know before covid and
uh hopefully will again and uh you know
it keeps me going like you said i'm
pretty old but i'm still
highly motivated and and i never said
you're pretty old i said but i
well it's true i am pretty old but i'm
still uh i'm still doing anesthesia
although i'm cutting back on time and uh
but my research keeps me going you know
it's it's what i love to do among other
things
what does your theory have to say about
zero point consciousness or the view
from nowhere
oh yeah nothingness yeah
so if in medi if you meditate uh it's
just contentless conscious
whether it's contentless or not uh
is is debatable some people say well
nothingness is something
um but i think you could be highly
conscious of just uh
pure conscious consciousness with
feelings i think you know
our feelings content i i think you know
it depends
it's a semantic question so i think you
can be highly conscious without any
content and sometimes that's the best
the best types of the best type of
consciousness when you say it's the best
type do you mean that it comes with
euphoria or do you mean that somehow
it's aiding your
regular life when you come back to it
well it could be the latter but you know
at the time i'm just thinking it's just
peaceful and euphoric and
in pure existence and and very
gratifying you know
have you heard of wolfram's
computational theory
i know will from what which computation
no his physics theory that says that
perhaps at the bottom of our universe is
something like hypergraphs
and there's a rule that dictates the
update of the hypergraph and then that
can
lead to regularities that we interpret
as particles and so on
it could be uh it sounds a little like
roger's idea but he wouldn't call it
computation i think you know the whole
idea of the brain is computers
the universe is a computer is maybe uh
its brain is more like an orchestra and
consciousness is more like music than a
computation
have you heard of bernardo castro's
theories of consciousness
a little bit yeah i know bernardo and
i've heard him speak and he's kind of an
idealist
and uh where consciousness is everything
and uh you know he has a rigorous
approach to it and i
and i respect that i just think that uh
you know matter is also real and
we kind of oscillate between a quantum
and a classical realm
at a high frequency so i don't think
it's quite right to say that
that consciousness is all there is i
think there's there's a real world out
there too a classical world what i was
wondering about your theory is how does
it solve the hard problem
when it seems like there's this material
base
and then there's a collapse and that
collapses consciousness but then i'm
wondering okay how is the collapse
consciousness because that's of a
different ontological category
so you're starting from material and
somehow you produce consciousness but it
still seems to me to lack an explanation
as to why consciousness arises
you have to you have to say that
experience is a fundamental component of
the universe
now a lot of people say that pan
cyclists pan cyclists say that
idealists say that ideally say that
that's all there is
uh pan psycho say would say i guess that
it's a property
of of matter that every atom has a
property or state
of of qualia of consciousness
and uh our approach is more
more of a process philosophy more along
the lines of alfred north whitehead
who said that consciousness is a
sequence of events
and doesn't even bring in matter you
know it's a sequence of events
of occasions of experience occurring in
a wider field
of of experience
and it was uh abner shimoni who
made the observation that whitehead's
occasions of experience are very much
like quantum state reductions
and whitehead was was aware of quantum
and didn't
and talked about a little bit but but
the idea is that consciousness is not
a property of matter but it's a it's an
event like a
photon is an event or um things are
events occurrences that that happen
rather than being states of matter
and what that does is the event cr
creates a particular state of matter so
if you have a superposition of
multiple possibilities and it collapses
to this
that's the state that's created and the
transition from going from
both to one emits i don't know if emit
is the proper
verb uh causes creates or is equivalent
to
a moment of conscious experience with
qualia you could say it's a quail it's
it's a quantum of
interesting what does your theory have
to say about free will
um well first of all you need the
backward time effect to be able to act
in real time uh it uh it doesn't address
determinism because even if you do act
in real time you still
have the problem well maybe it was
always going to be that way because of
everything else that
that's already happened but when you
bring in the backward time effects i
think that gives you the possibility
of free will but you're still you're
still governed by
if that's true you're still governed by
you know the deterministic schroding
equation up to that point
and uh and uh you know maybe even the
platonic values so
you know the best they could say is that
the free will is the experience
of your volition being influenced by
platonic values
and actually i have a paper about that
called how quantum brain biology can
rescue conscious free will
but it deals with the backward time
effect rather than the other the other
issues
but is published already
in 2012 uh uh how quantum brain biology
can rescue conscious free will
and i think it's got more views than any
other paper i've written
it's in one of the frontiers journals
something like 50 000 views
i'll link it in the description okay now
this question i'm not sure if it's
better directed at penrose or to you and
i'm not sure who's the obverse
of the two but i'll for the sake of
flattering you'll pretend it i'll say
it's you
for this conversation there's a strong
anthropic principle and a weak one
now as far as i know actually i don't
recall which is which so let me see
well you can explain it i can't find it
right now
one has the causal arrow going in the
other direction yeah well basically the
anthropic principle is that uh
uh the if you look at the 20 or so
values of the parameters that govern the
universe the charge of this and the
the sep and uh uh all the things that
govern
at the microscope right right right
level okay if they weren't
exactly if all 22 i think weren't
exactly what they were
what they are we wouldn't have a
universe with with stars
light life and consciousness so they
have to be exactly
exactly how they are for us to be here
and one view is that it you know
uh god did it you know that there's a
prime mover and he created he or she
created the universe the way it is
and that i think that's the strong
anti-anatomic principle
i'm not sure uh the other view is that
um is that
it brings in multiple worlds and that
there's an infinite number of
worlds and that we happen to live in the
one world
the one and only world that has all the
parameters right that can have
consciousness
so that um uh all the other worlds they
don't have cut so
it it solves the problem of you know the
that we won the cosmic lottery by having
all these numbers being exactly
the way they are by saying well that's
that's only because
it's it's a uh it's a selector's bias
that you know we're asking the questions
because we're in the one and only
universe that has
the pro that has consciousness um
but then you have all these other worlds
what's the you know what's the point
um so i don't like that and then uh
chalmers
and uh kelvin mcqueen tried to to say
they have kind of a
copenhagen view of consciousness causes
collapse
and they were saying well consciousness
coming from another uh multiple worlds
i think they were saying that and i said
well that's the case to be coming from
a world with inferior inferior
consciousness because of
the end so they they drop that so
the explanation i like is
uh we actually talked about this in our
in our recent papers
you know roger has his whole own theory
about cyclical conformal cosmology
that the big bang was preceded by
another eon and that was preceded by
another eon and so forth
and uh i saw i said well why do you
think there was
uh consciousness in the previous eon he
said well sure
sure it could have been should have been
why not and uh
i then thought about a a book by uh lee
smolin
about called life of the cosmos and uh
he was talking about uh in a black hole
okay evolutionary model pardon me
an evolutionary model yeah that that
what comes down on the other side
is an improved version of what what went
in
so i said could that apply to your you
know big bangs and
in eons so that that uh every transition
from e on the e on
the parameters mutate or evolve
and so what comes out on the other side
is a slightly improved
or maybe dramatically improved version
of the parameters to support
consciousness
and that you know the universe is
evolving e on the eon to optimize
consciousness
so i was a little surprised he didn't
just say no
and said yeah it could be so we put that
in the that's in one of our recent
papers suggesting that
that consciousness is actually steering
the universe
um by these transition points uh big
bang transition points
and then e on the e on consciousness
gets a little bit better each time
instead of universes giving rise to one
where there are great conditions for
intelligence self-consciousness
that is the multiverse theory the weak
anthropic principle
you have consciousness is driving the
progression of the universe
evolutionarily as in penrose's cyclical
model
okay so then this to me implies that
there are better laws or more
adaptive physical constants so do you or
penrose make any predictions
as to what would be considered better
for consciousness
in terms of further tweaking these
fundamental constants
i can't tell you exactly you know what
would be what would improve
consciousness
uh but with all these 22 parameters
you know there must be some combination
that might optimize it in the sense that
how i don't know how but you know maybe
the platonic values are
evolving maybe the experience is getting
more fun
or feels better i don't know but
how would you you know if you want to
improve consciously well you know what
would be a way to improve it
outside of getting rid of people want to
kill other people and that sort of thing
but
you know just how would it get better
i'm not sure but i think
i think it's one possibility what else i
mean what what else would be the point
of
of the universe evolving to improve what
in other words i don't see consciousness
as kind of a of an afterthought i think
of it as more
more primary
at one point you mentioned that you can
vibrate literally vibrate the
microtubules to
treat cognitive disorders and that you
did this to yourself at some point
okay what were the results of that and
can this be done at home
i got to be careful here for and not
practice medicine over the internet but
but uh when uh when honor bond came out
with this idea that
or discovered that there were these
vibrations in microtubules
uh including in megahertz then um
[Music]
you know so he had terahertz gigahertz
megahertz kilohertz
so i said i wonder if there's a way to
treat the microtubule so
terahertz is is infrared and people
actually do try that but
it's kind of hard to get photons into
the brain gigahertz is
microwaves i wasn't interested in
putting microwaves in my brain although
that's that
apparently that uh that weapon that the
russians or the i forgot who used it
on our embassy people these loud pops
and apparently that was microwave
and so i wasn't interested in doing that
megahertz is in electromagnetics as
radio waves
wasn't interested in doing that but
megahertz in mechanical
is ultrasound and we use ultrasound and
anesthesia all the time
and so when i read this i looked over
and there's an ultrasound machine
sitting there
and i said i wonder if anybody's put
ultrasound into the brain
and ultrasound's been around forever and
it's mechanical vibrations megahertz
bounces off
echoes off surfaces so you get an image
inside the body you can see the
babies in the uterus and so forth and so
i
i looked up and sure enough a guy had
been putting ultrasound into the brains
of animals and getting behavioral
effects
and uh you know they could move their
paw you could get it you can make them
move their paw by
hitting the paw paw region and
physiological effects
and uh i wondered uh what would be the
effect on mental states
and uh um it ultrasound is approved for
have been approved for imaging the brain
so people in me getting ultrasound of
the brain but it wasn't very good
compared to you know mri and ct for
imaging the brain so it wasn't really
useful
so i said to my anesthesia colleagues
you know we have we have chronic pain
patients who are depressed in addition
to taking p
taking care of people in the operating
room for surgery we
see chronic pain patients do nerve
blocks and sort of thing and i'd i'd
done our i worked in our pain clinic a
while and i said you know they're all
depressed maybe we should put ultrasound
into their brain
and see if they feel better all over the
brain or in a specific region well i
didn't i didn't get that far
and that you know i hadn't really
thought about it and uh and my friend
said
okay you go first you know we don't try
to anybody
unless we try it on ourselves well you
have an easy head for it
yeah that's true i do and uh
but it was also my idea in fact that's
what he said that's what my friend said
he said you got a shaved head
your idea you go first and so it's the
end of the day we're sitting around
the table and i said okay what the heck
i thought about it and i really well
it's
approved for ultrasound brain imaging it
can't be that bad
how many seconds sorry it's interrupt
how many seconds does it take for the
imaging
like a minute imaging happens
immediately
okay so they don't leave prolonged
ultrasound on your brain at least not in
humans
that they've tested well i i
i'm not sure anybody used it for brain
imaging very much it was approved but
then ctm or i came came by came around
so i don't know if it was
there wasn't any guidelines i you know i
knew what they used in animals and that
sort of thing
anyway so they called my bluff my
friends call my bluff
and uh sit around the table and i picked
it up with my right hand
and uh you put this goo on it because
it's got to have gel
and being right-handed and knowing that
the temporal bone is the thinnest i put
it right here
turned on the machine saw would sort of
look like my brain on the
on the screen kept it there for about 15
seconds
put it down i didn't feel a thing i said
oh well that's disappointing
but about a minute later i did start to
feel anything to feel something and i
felt kind of a buzz i was like
really energized and invigorated and
felt really good for about an hour
and so i said you know what we should
try this so we did the first uh
study in 19 in 2012 it was actually
published in 2013 of chronic pain
patients
in the journal brain stimulation and
showed improved mood and reduced pain
and chronic pain patients
with 15 seconds of ultrasound to uh
contralateral to the pain in pain
chronic pain patients
in a double blind crossover study you
don't feel it so it's easy to do a
double blind study
now since then a number of other people
did it and we we did a study about a
year ago
uh with much better studies showed
improved mood and
changing mri connectivity so it actually
does
does change the connection patterns in
the brain
did you ever try it again i've tried it
a couple times
uh but nothing again not that you didn't
get that one hour of buzz
yeah i did but i didn't yeah but
have you tried it for creativity what's
that have you tried it to increase
creativity or
productivity i i don't i don't i don't
want to mess with it it's something
at work you know i i don't have one at
home it's not
something i'm really into to trying but
i think if i had alzheimer's or
or something like that i damn well try
it okay let me get off on a hypothetical
plunge here
some people suggest that the universe as
a whole is conscious now i assume you
suggest that to some minor degree
proto-consciousness more like a
cacophony than a symphony because you
need to cohere it in some manner
okay but then consciousness is
associated with
40 hertz 10 hertz it could be at any
frequency
okay where i was going with this was you
can look at the universe as a whole
through astrological data
and in cosmological data and i'm
wondering
is there a way of seeing if the universe
is vibrating
and then let's imagine it's not
vibrating at some level
then does that mean that as far as we
can tell we are the most
conscious parts of the universe well it
may be vibrating questions whether it's
vibrating coherently
you know or is everything connected and
uh
some people would say yes and
everything's entangled you know going
back to the big bang everything's
entangled
you're kind of asking me whether you
know whether there's god out there
in terms of this and i think there might
be but i'm not gonna
you know i don't want to say yes or no
for sure i think there's something like
god
and uh and it could it it has to do with
uh you know platonic values and
consciousness out there but
i'd rather leave it vague because
otherwise it becomes religion
okay well then what i was wondering is
let's imagine that we are the most
conscious parts of the universe now i
know that's extreme hubris then does
that mean that
we have a chance at directing the
evolution toward
the universe being more conscious in the
next cycle
if consciousness is somehow directing
the evolution of these cycles and we
happen to be the most
conscious in this universe then do we
have some hand
at that this is a huge speculative jump
yeah yeah i know i know i mean
i did speculate that uh roger and i did
speculate that you know these crossovers
of e on the eon
but just to get there you know you have
to have this key death of the universe
and
and i think we would long be long gone
and it would be our consciousness
somehow you know in the in the plank
scale and the fine scale structure of
the universe whatever that is
so i don't know that's that's a tough
one
what do you agree with deepak chopra on
and what do you disagree with him on
i was watching the interview between you
and him and i said this on the
a most recent interview i did with
bernardo castro that
i'm i don't disagree necessarily with
deepak it's not like i agree or disagree
because i just
reserve judgment i don't know the idea
is enough but i see him as
looking for scientific credibility from
people so when you say something that
is in line with what he thinks he'll ask
you to
expound and then say well what do you
say to people who disagree and say that
i
espouse well you're a scientist and you
believe some
so i see him as fishing for scientific
credibility
rather than someone who is open to
different viewpoints and is challenging
his own
in the moment but i'm curious what you
think of deepak
were you agreeing where you disagree
well he's a friend of mine
uh and uh you know i've heard the
criticisms
and and that you know i think he's he's
uh
he can be criticized along the lines of
what you what you said but
his heart's in a good place and he means
well and uh let's just leave it at that
he's a friend of mine when people say
that
we're all one and not in just some
abstract sense but in that we share
some entity what do you make of that
like consciousness is fundamental uh i
think we can be one i think i think you
know people can be entangled
i don't uh you know i think esp and that
sort of thing parapsychology can't
can occur by quantum non-locality but
does that mean we are
all entangled at any one time not
necessarily i think potentially we can
be but
uh again i don't want to go too far in
that direction i've already
i've gone on quite a limb in a lot of
areas
okay i'll take some questions from the
audience so let's take a look here
is the depressed person more or less
conscious
well you could say they're less
conscious but they would require the
same amount of anesthesia probably
so i'd say they're probably uh
the same but just on a negative poll you
know you can have
good news and bad news but it's all news
but but on the other hand i do have a
graph in one of my papers where
we plot the number of tubulins and you
know uh
versus uh ease of gene and
so the intensity of the conscious
experience would be related to the
frequency
of the uh of the number of orca wire
events you can have so a plant cell
might have
you know a few per minute and we can we
might have you know uh
trillions per second so yes
there are levels of consciousness but
within humans it's it's kind of hard to
say
this being depressed doesn't really
necessarily make you less conscious
you certainly feel less conscious but
maybe that's the same thing
but would stewart be interested in
seeing raw neural signals
in awake primates that show timing
supporting
his time predictions for network
properties and i just read that
verbatim i don't quite understand what's
going on so perhaps you do
there was support what okay would
stewart be interested in seeing raw
neural signals
in awake primates that show timings
supporting his timing predictions
for network properties if you mean
something that shows a response before
the stimulus the backward time effect
yes
and i suspect they're all over
neuroscience and they get buried
because people don't want to deal with
them we had a talk to one of our
conferences and
somebody was showing uh implanted
electrodes in patients
and with response to different different
uh faces
you know the halle berry neuron would
fire the bill clinton neuron with fire
and it seemed that the uh the uh the
firing which he was showing on the
screen were happening slightly before
the picture appeared
and i said are they synchronized and he
said yes
i said so you mean the neuron responds
just before the
before the picture actually appears he
goes yes
and he said well i said well how do you
explain that he goes i can't
and uh i said you think they're backward
time effects
he said i don't know he wouldn't go he
wouldn't go there this was christoph
koch student
at the time and i invited him to the
next year's conference to talk about
that and he showed up and he talked
about something different i said why
don't you talk about the backward time
effect
he said kristoff said it would ruin my
career really
that would ruin his career what's uh has
this been published
no but there's been a lot of stuff
published on backward time you know
daryl bem had
uh you know eight to eight experiment
and nine experiments eight of nine
eight out of nine of which showed back
with time effects
okay do you mind repeating that person's
name this way i can darryl
eem a psychologist oh
back in 2012 something like that in a
mainstream
psychology journal did uh nine
experiments
showing uh uh and eight of them showed
essentially backward time effects see
i'm
super super interested in talking to
people who
have done studies that demonstrate
something that seems like esp
or near death experiences or paranormal
psi events because
unlike most of the physicists i don't
see it as
contradicting physics i see it as
perhaps there's this is indicating new
physics
or the way that consciousness interacts
with physics which to me is
part of an explanatory framework right
and roger's working on this
retroactivity
now which could explain this but he's
doing it as a way to get rid of the uh
well for a different reason because of
the uh
to his objective reduction in the tails
problem and quantum collapse and i
i don't know that much about but uh
hopefully we'll hear more about that in
our next paper because
he said he's working on it andreas cole
says i'm so excited for this
could you ask him what he thinks about
open individualism
and what theory of self he personally
subscribes to
and then what does orkoar say about that
said theory of self
um i'm not sure what different theories
of self are
i have this debate with with betsy my
wife all the time because
uh she and many people think you need
self to have consciousness and i
don't think you need a self to have
consciousness i think you can just have
uh experiences that over time
build up memories and the memories
itself so
uh i'm not committed you know and then
julian james you know had this idea that
hundreds of thousands of years ago there
was no one
you there's no one curt in your head
there's no one steward in my head
it was just a bunch of voices and uh
and you know the gods or the gremlins or
whoever
and then over over time it consolidated
into itself
so i don't think you need a self to to
be conscious i think
and of course if you know the whole
point of meditation is to lose
self so uh i i
i don't worry about that too much and i
think if you have a seat
sequence uh you know over the course of
a lifetime of conscious moments and
memory
you're going to have a self built up but
that doesn't mean it's the self having
the consciousness
consciousness could just be it's you
know occurring by its
by itself have you researched much about
jung
because what you described sound like
what jung described as the individuation
process
and that is that there are different
personalities disparate maybe disjoint
that are competing and conflicting
it could be yeah i i'm not a i know a
little bit about young
and uh uh betsy studies young and my
my good friend harold ottman spocker is
big on young
um but uh
i don't really know that much about it
okay and lastly dan arms says
does he think there may be any basis to
the hypothesis
that the sun has consciousness the sun
yeah uh the only thing i want to say
about that is that uh
roger once said that neutron stars
uh have giant bose-einstein condensates
so they could have moments of collapse
and a neutron star might be having
conscious moments but
other other types of stars i don't know
stuart thank you so much man hey you're
welcome
good talking to you good luck to you yes
great questions thanks for your audience
and uh
uh stay in touch
you